did you know the entire plot of
malignant is right there in the opening
credits but you were too stupid to
notice let's start with the credits
themselves annabelle wallace is the
actress who plays the pro tag madison
mitchell all of the repeated letters in
her name that is the n's the l's and the
other l's start as one letter then
divide into two this process mirrors the
cell division that we later learn
occurred to create the parasitic twin at
gabriel the actual footage shown during
the title sequence also spoils the movie
if you can comprehend it it's assumed
that the surgery clips we're seeing or
the procedure on gabriel mentioned in
the opening but stopping at just the
right moment shows that the patient name
is emily may which we later learn is
madison's real name a medical diagram
shows a girl with eyes looking in
different directions as a result of the
craniopagus and emily's file mentions
sleepwalking hallucinations and waking
dreams all of which are eventually
attributed to gabriel hijacking her
brain
we're starting to suspect that gabriel
can somehow access the region to the
brain that process visual stimuli and
make emily see what he wants her to see
this would explain her recent claims of
hallucinations and waking dreams another
page adds malnourishment to our list of
symptoms we come to find out that
gabriel was essentially feeding off of
her fetuses to build himself back up he
was the hidden cause of all of her
miscarriages we even see brain scans
that seem to highlight the tumor on the
backside of her head and this file
describes craniofacial features
including two fully formed faces while
making a comparison to janus cats a rare
condition in cats that causes him to be
born with two faces the name was
inspired by janus the roman god of past
and future who is depicted as having two
faces one looking into the past and one
to the future toward the end of the
title sequence a page in this binder
spells out the condition of craniopagus
parasiticus which is the type of
parasitic twinning that is bound to
madison and gabriel to share one brain
there are many other clues about
malignant's terrifying twist nested
throughout the entire movie and many
other things you might have missed to
learn the meaning behind the hidden
symbol on detective shaw's computer
screen the clue hidden in the movie
soundtrack meanings behind character
names and more stick around to the end
of this video sponsored by mgm slots
live
welcome to things you missed in 2016
director james wan released the
conjuring 2 his 4th demonic possession
movie after this he would take a little
break from the horror genre but when he
came back he wanted to do something new
he came back with an original concept
developed by his wife actress writer
producer ingrid bisou who had a long
time fascination with teratomes and
parasitic twins ingrid also has a
character in this movie named cst winnie
i believe csd stands for crime scene
technician she's the one doing the
hands-on investigating and she's clearly
passionate about her job this would
reflect your interest in the idea of a
villainous parasitic twin in real life
her character also has a crush on the
asian detective oh here comes miss
lonely heart claw
you have to believe that this character
represents james wan the head of the
investigation the director of the movie
james wanted to get back to his roots
with a police procedural serial crime
movie like his breakout hit saw while
also expanding into new territory
there's a bit of mystery there's a bit
of creature feature monster aspect to it
there's a serial killer aspect to it
he's also talked about the influence of
italian giallo horror films like the
nightmares of dario argento and the body
horror stylings of david cronenberg i'll
get into some more specific examples
when we get into the things you missed
so let's get in to the things you
why do we do this
why do we always open the show this way
the opening company logos are altered to
look like we're watching them on an old
crt monitor this makes them match the
video diaries from the simeon research
facility where we learn about madison
and gabriel's past but also might be a
reference to what james wan might have
seen while watching old giallo films on
tv as a teenager in the 1990s the first
diary we see is from emily and gabriel's
doctor florence weaver and she has a
bust of a man with an exposed brain this
is likely for demonstration purposes but
it also serves as a precursor to gabriel
who emerges by poking through madison's
skull also seen on the shelf is her
medical research association award which
later becomes gabriel's main weapon it's
originally a large spike surrounded by a
tapering double snake helix and angelic
wings the helix one viewed from above
creates a spiral a symbol that's become
an element of james wand's auteur as a
director i also noticed a similar
tapering helix on the plants outside of
dr gregory's apartment shortly before
he's taken out by gabriel gabriel also
makes his lair in the attic and we
answer it via a big spiraling camera
movement as gabriel makes modifications
to this trophy this movement is also
something we've seen before in wan's
work like this shot and saw or this shot
in dead silence after removing the
snakes gabriel keeps the angelic wings
effectively serving as a hilt for his
new weapon this ties into a theme that
madison talks about much later on the
idea that gabriel is essentially a demon
in hiding the name gabriel comes from
the biblical messenger angel gabriel i
imagine it was chosen to hide his true
evil nature
he pretends to be nice
that he's the devil gabriel likes to
position himself in high places i
already talked about the attic but he
also attacks serena from above and he
attacks shaw from above on multiple
occasions but when he's discovered and
chased he retreats to where he's most at
home the seattle underground
representative of hell it is also the
basement of the research facility where
sydney discovers the files containing
the truth about gabriel where the
graffiti makes the analogy a little bit
more obvious the idea that gabriel is a
devil posing as an angel is also
reflected in the camera work many of the
attacks feature this top-down view on
the victim the house even contains
stained-glass window artwork something
we've certainly seen before in
residential houses but something you're
more likely to associate with the church
the biblical gabriel was a messenger
angel who communicated with the prophet
daniel to explain his visions malignant
gabriel literally gives madison visions
and communicates with her via tvs and
radius gabriel's mother serena might
have predicted his true nature if she
had listened to her parents in one of
the tapes she explains her mom and dad
were religious and she saw the teen
pregnancy as a transgression against god
finally the police gather information on
serena and if you look carefully her
social security number begins with 666
the number of the devil after the intro
with dr weaver we meet the current day
emily may who now goes by madison
mitchell she has a child of her own on
the way but when gabriel comes back into
her life we can spot even more secrets
thank you mgm slots live for sponsoring
this video download link is in the
description mjm slots live brings the
excitement of las vegas casinos straight
to the palm of your hand wherever you
are in the world the game features
loyalty points so the more you play the
more you collect with these points you
can redeem real life rewards like free
hotel rooms discounted meals and show
tickets at any mgm resorts property and
many other partners around the world you
can also play live slot in bingo
tournaments against other players from
around the world and its top games
include piggy pop flashy cash wicked
fortunes and the win zone download mgm
slots live using the link in the
description or scan the qr code right
here on your screen let's face it you're
going to use the link in the description
and get 10 million free chips if you're
a new player available in the ios app
store and google play it's that easy
just click the link
click the link just click the link in
the description to go to the landing
page and i'll see you in the game
[Music]
madison gets home to find her husband
derek watching a ufc match on tv which
depicts a fighter punching his opponents
on the back of the head this is a
foreshadowing of the incident that would
soon occur where derek pushes his wife
into a wall and she cracks open the back
of her head allowing gabriel to surface
there are a couple instances in the
movie of butterfly motifs like the
wallpaper at the simeon facility and
sydney's outfit when she visits madison
in the hospital a butterfly takes flight
only after coming out of its cocoon it
kind of reminds me of the image of
gabriel poking his head out of the back
of madison's skull it's hard to say if
that was intentional the analogy isn't
perfect because gabriel could never take
flight and leave madison's body because
he's just a parasite he needs her to
survive but there are some more concrete
clues about who and what gabriel really
is when he strikes derek if you're
paying close attention you'll notice
that his hand is upside down from what
you'd expect try it right now take your
right hand and do a nice overhead snack
with your fingers pointing down unless
you're extremely flexible this will feel
very unnatural that's because this is
actually the left hand going behind the
back the police do pick up on this but
they have a different theory about how
it was achieved
no fingerprints but all the hand
patterns are upside down like our purp
was hanging from the ceiling they also
note that there was no forced entry into
the house because gabriel was already
inside derek's head is twisted around
180 degrees causing his face to
essentially look backwards just like
gabriel he's fixing his victims to look
like him we also see him do this at the
jail where one of the victim's arms is
pulled back in the opposite direction of
the joint and at the police station
where an officer's limbs are bent back
the wrong way madison tries to cope by
saying
she is correct but it's not her
imagination it's literally in the back
of her head you know who i am
when she was young the surgeons cut out
as much of the cancer as possible only
leaving what was necessary for madison
to survive the rest of gabriel was
buried under her skull the way the tour
guide describes old seattle seems
symbolic of what happened to gabriel
this is a tour of old seattle buried
underneath here like a time capsule of a
bygone era of course after her school is
cracked open gabriel's face can push its
way back to the surface which may be the
inspiration for the wording of this line
by detective moms i read about one more
sick kid my brain's gonna push out my
eyeballs i mentioned that gabriel is
able to essentially hijack madison's
brain and make her see visions of the
crimes that he commits when he's in
control in her hallucinations gabriel
often emerges from the back side of her
head first during the death scene of dr
fields then again when gabriel comes for
dr gregory after each hallucination she
wakes up with fresh stains on her pillow
because that's where gabriel had pushed
his way out when madison uses the
bathroom at the police station we can
see the back of her head in the mirror
is it just me or is there something
mysterious about the dark parts in her
hair right here
kiff i'm asking you a question after
escaping from detective shaw it becomes
more clear that he's running backwards
and he continually inverts himself when
he's fleeing down the fire escape the
scene reminds me a lot of john doe's
escape in seven which makes me think
that james wan was probably also
inspired by fellow director david
fincher the biggest fincher connection
though is in malignant soundtrack there
will be major spoilers for fight club so
if you haven't seen it skip to the end
of this chapter fight club has a
somewhat similar twist ending the main
character has a split personality and at
the end he purges him by killing off the
second personality in malignant the
voice in madison's head is more of a
literal person but she defeats him by
locking him away in her mind fight club
famously ends with the song where is my
mind by the pixies like if you look up
the song on youtube the top comments are
all about fight club the two are that
intertwined the song we hear over and
over again during the transitions in
malignant is clearly inspired by where
is my mind
[Music]
it seems to be a little clue from james
wan that malignant shares more than one
thing in common with fight club but as i
mentioned the biggest source of
inspiration seems to come from giallo an
italian genre of mystery thriller horror
stories primarily in the 60s and 70s the
way gabriel fashions himself is very
much like a typical giallo villain but
i'll save that for when i cover gabriel
in horror history but there are other
examples though like when the tv turns
on and the first thing we hear sounds
like an italian film
dr weaver keeps her records in bellagio
italia binders when gabriel comes for dr
fields at his apartment the place is
illuminated in red and neon lights
colorful neon lighting is a hallmark of
giallo films and they often depict a
clash of reds and blues along with
gabriel's silhouettes this scene is
clearly an homage as a side note the red
light is being emitted from this sign
outside which says silver cup silver cup
is a production facility in new york
city i'm guessing parts of malignant
were filmed there but as for this sign
it's not quite the same as the real life
sign so i'm guessing they created that
in a sound studio in the movie silver
cup is an apartment complex not a
production studio interestingly silver
cup was also a working title for
malignant it's not a very big part of
the story so i'm guessing it was just
used early on to hide what the movie
might really be about but the scene
across from the silver cup sign also
shares a huge similarity with another
horror film from james wan's filmography
[Music]
the way that gabriel appears from the
open window in dr phil's apartment is
very reminiscent of another james wand
villain appearance this one in a motel
during his 2007 film at dead silence the
antagonist mary shaw appears in front of
the flowing curtain illuminated only by
the buzzing neon sign across the way in
fact when madison sees the vision of dr
field's fate the red light flickers in a
very similar manner to the mary shaw
encounter that brings me to my next one
connection the name shaw comes up a lot
in his work whether it's dead silence's
mary shaw malignant detective kakoa shaw
or even furious 7's deckard shaw and
owen shaw although owen shaw did appear
in the previous film fast and furious 6
which james wan was not involved with
and technically deckard shaw did too but
he only appeared in the end credits so
he's mostly a furious 7 character
speaking of non-horror movies directed
by juan his previous effort before
malignant was called aquaman yeah they
literally made a movie out of aquaman
fame led to book deals movie appearances
and hit records i guess detective shaw
must be a fan when he's playing the
video on his laptop the aquaman logo
appears in the bottom corner of the
screen it's not there before his first
name is also kakoa the actor who plays
the young version of aquaman is named
kikoa kekamanu so there's definitely a
reference there there might also be a
saw connection with him he's part of an
asian black detective duo i can't help
but wonder if this is a nod two
detectives sing and tap from the
original song normally i don't talk
about actor cameos but i do find it a
little bit interesting that both the
young and old versions of madison are
played by actresses from the annabelle
movies which are produced by james wan
as part of his conjuring franchise
before i talk about the significance
behind the character names there are a
few more points that i'd like to mention
so might as well do them here the first
tape we see from dr weaver has a time
code at the top and once it gets to 11
59 it just resets back to 11 instead of
moving on to 12. probably just a glitch
that no one noticed i just found it kind
of weird then also in the opening
sequence when gabriel is rampaging
there's a child's picture on the wall
depicting thunder clouds and lightning
that might just be a normal day for kids
in seattle but it could be connected to
gabriel's ability to manipulate
electricity then during the second
break-in that isn't really a break-in
the camera circles around madison and we
see both sides of her head this is a
great setup for the big reveal of
gabriel and it makes his presence even
more shocking blaming everything on an
evil twin is one of the oldest excuses
in the book but i guess this is one of
those rare times where it's also
actually the truth sydney drives a
toyota prius which is a hybrid vehicle
madison later drives this car as well
madison could be considered a hybrid of
gabriel and emily may honestly it's
probably just product placement i also
thought that maybe the fact that madison
and gabriel have the same phone was a
clue at one point but then i realized
literally everyone in the movie has the
same phone for some reason okay so i
already talked about the religious
implications behind the name gabriel so
while this character is clearly linked
to the supernatural the other names in
the story are named after real things
found in nature sydney's last name is
lake the female detective is moss one of
the doctors is fields and even shaw is
an english scottish name meaning one who
dwells by the woods sydney's first name
may also be an example the name sydney
means wide meadow and serena's first
name obviously means serene clear and
tranquil all words that could be used to
describe nature also there's a woman in
jail whose name is scorpion that just
leaves our main character madison
mitchell whose birth name was emily may
madison and may are both connected
madison traditionally means son of
matthew while may references the goddess
maya or the family of matthew if for
some reason someone watching the movie
knew that it could be a clue that these
characters are one in the same if you're
a fan of james wants horror movies like
saw dead silence insidious and the
conjuring then you're in luck because i
have a whole playlist with my analyses
on his other works which you can find on
the left remember to subscribe to cz's
world for new horrors every week ring
the death bell and select all
notifications and
why do we always end it like this i'll
see you in the next one assuming we both
survive
[Music]